[Music]
tonight we're talking about Justin
Timberlake now we cannot wait until
Super Bowl 52 now I got his wife Jessica
Biel talking about all things oh my Peas
halftime show and guess what she has a
big role in the Super Bowl Sunday now
your husband said that he puts you in
charge of all the tickets oh I didn't
know someone's in trouble
and all the tickets will be gone Super
Bowl tickets just one of the perks of
being mrs. Timberlake the other bean mom
too little Silas who last we heard was
getting to be a handful he's hitting his
terrible twos a little early so we're
hoping he'll get out of him a little
early is he done with the terrible twos
there's a lot of no going on in my house
we are definitely the mix Silas isn't
all that's keeping Jessica busy her new
oh fudge kid's camp is set to open in
mid-november
it's an extension of the family-friendly
la restaurant she co-owns with her
partners you can just drop in here if
you want to and you know sit here and
watch your kid play but we really want
it to be you know imagination based
creative based but first the Timberlake
family's getting ready for Halloween
last year was a nod to Justin's trolls
movie this year we are going to be Woody
and Buzz and Jessie from Toy Story
Jessica's gonna be Jessica from toys
you
[Music]